um so comrad thank you very much for
that uh nice introduction so I'm an
interim Chief data scientist I go into
teams that are lacking a senior and help
the team figure out how to ship things
of value and I do that because I see so
many teams not shipping things of value
um and struggling and I've done like 25
years of of doing all of this including
a bunch of conference talks on hey
here's how not to screw up your data
science projects no don't make my
mistakes make new mistakes but uh uh
learn how to ship things uh successfully
uh also I really care about high
performance computing this goes back
like 30 or years for me uh and as comrad
noted I'm co-author of O'Reilly's high
performance python we've just signing
the contract for the Third Edition we'll
be working on that for next year and one
of the co-founders of pil London 13,000
members nearly 10 years of volunteering
now with a wonderful uh UK organizing
group behind us all um jles will be
attending uh in the chat uh not
co-presenting with me he's my co-author
of this talk and he's worked in a bunch
of big organizations like the office for
National statistics and shell dealing
with big data problems with tools like
desk and Spark uh so what are we talking
about here here we're going to contrast
three data frame libraries uh pandas
dask and polers one of several talks
that you've probably seen here at Global
this year already there's been a lot of
change in the ecosystem in the last
bunch of years we used to just have
pandas and then to do pandas uh on
bigger than Ram situations we turned to
desk uh there have been a couple of
other data frame libraries and now
polers is a couple of years into the
scene and is growing well um so which
should you use and here's a question for
you uh I'd love it if in the chat you
could just go and type in what it is
that you use and Charles will keep an
eye on that uh because we're always
curious about the the balance of how
people are using the use different tools
so do you use pandas polers desk or
something else um when we first did this
talk um at P to London six months ago
we've been using polers for two weeks
and we got really impressive benchmarks
I was really impressed with that uh here
we've been using it on and off over
seven months and getting a bit deeper
into it uh one of the interesting things
about our talk uh as a contrast to some
of the other talks is although we use
all the these libraries and we know some
of the core developers we're not aligned
with any one of these projects so I
don't mind having benchmarks that show
that a project is doing better or doing
worse I just want benchmarks that
represent a problem what problem do we
tackle well early in the year with some
old friends of mine not with JS but with
some old friends we decided to do a
silly thing we were going to do a
charity Car Rally Join one of these
Banger car rallies uh where we have to
buy a car more than 20 years old and
less than ,000 so a cheap old car and
drive it through Europe 2,000 miles up
and over the Alps over to Italy to
Venice and back in a week raising money
for charity uh brilliant idea it's got
nothing to do with data science at all
but it gives us uh an excuse to get an
interesting data set uh note that last
uh bullet point ideally the car
shouldn't explode you will see some
Peril halfway through this talk uh what
data set did this enable Giles and I to
go and play with well uh here in the UK
we have the driving vehicle licensing
Authority they look after the safety
certificates for all of the vehicles
that are on the road uh you can get per
open data about 20 years worth of road
test data for all the vehicles that are
licensed to be on the road so there's
about 30 billion Vehicles a year it
comes a bunch of CSV files which all
come in different formats every couple
of years the format changes the joy of
CSV uh and tsv um and you get about 600
million rows worth of data and it's a
good mix of ins and dates and strings uh
and a few other bits uh and if you go to
the check mot Service uh online the
government uh website online you can get
up say the records of EV Volvo 50 our
first car the one that has the Peril
associated with it and if you then go
and look in those CSV records you can
find exactly that vehicle and its test
history over the years so we've got a
nice large data set and we use Dash to
convert it to park uh so let's get on
with the tools pandas pandas 2 uh so
this has been out uh for a little while
now um uh it was pretty recent when we
gave the last version of The Talk pan
this is about 15 years old historically
it was numpy based numpy being the
numeric p layer allowing one-dimensional
vectors two dimensional arrays and N
dimensional arrays of all of the
Primitive types and so this was used uh
to uh provide the series uh and the data
frames inside pandas uh which was super
easy but also came with some warts one
of the big warts being it didn't have
good missing data handling we just
inherited what the the Nan support on
floats uh that was available in numpy
then there was an extension type system
uh added to pandas um and uh more
recently in the last couple of years
we've had arrows so arrows a very
different uh memory container
crossplatform cross Library so you can
share data between pandas and poers and
between R and Julia and other systems
anything that supports uh Arrow you can
share that data very easily uh and store
at the dis uh in parkades the same
storage system there so that's now baked
into pandas that's really interesting
but it's different to numpy and it means
a lot of the internals had to be
Rewritten and changed to support that
and that's hurt some of the benchmarks
and improved others um and also we have
copy on right now it's still off by
default in pandas 2 it'll be turned on
in pandas 3 sometime next year uh that
seems to be really interesting and I've
got a couple of benchmarks here so first
of all let's have a look at uh uh two
benchmarks in Panda so this is a 2 by
two table uh it looks a bit weird so
these four screenshots represent uh
either string D types such is on the uh
uh on the the col axis string D type or
a group bu and then on the row AIS
Apache Arrow uh and then numpy so top
left uh if we've got a string dtype uh
dfda that's a my data frame pandas PD
with arrow as a container dfda I take
the make column that's the name of the
uh the vehicle Toyota Volkswagen and do
string length as an operation that takes
about 1 second uh so that's pretty cool
uh on uh on a lot of rows that I've got
in this data set I think 82 million rows
that are in memory if I do the same
thing on a string and some of you who do
string operations will know this uh you
do this on a string in DF PDN so this is
the numpy backend equivalent of pandas
so the the default the thing that we've
been using for decades uh the same
operation takes about 8 seconds so eight
times slower that's that's kind of huge
and actually if we look at the the
difference in memory size between the
numpy backend versus this data and the
arrow back end the numpy backend 82
million rows 39 gigabyte versus 11
gigabyte uh for the arrow backend so
it's a three four times memory size
difference um and some operations like s
operations much slower um but uh is it
is it the case that always arrow is
going to be faster for us well not
necessarily sometimes the numeric
benchmarks are faster some are slower uh
there are some things that seem to be
not yet fixed uh there are some perf
reports in the uh Panda's issue tracker
uh Group by manipulation slow with the
new engine um some of these were fixed
many months ago um however there seemed
to be a crop of them that just keep on
popping up and it took me less than a
minute to find a combination on my data
where I could reliably say that group
byy on an integer field in this case and
then taking a numeric operation of mean
on another integer field took two and a
half seconds with arrow imp pandas as
opposed to just over a second with the
numpy back end so some things are faster
some things are slower um I don't know
if that's good or bad uh but it's worth
pointing out that if you do your own
benchmarks and you're just switching
over to Arrow be aware that some things
might not be as good as you're hoping
for but other things could be better uh
what about copy on right so by default
and it's still the case now by default
copy on right is disabled this means
that whenever pandas has a a data frame
modification for a certain set of those
modifications and three of them I've
chosen here rename aign and drop they
they fo a foul of this whenever those
modifications occur then a defensive
data frame copy is made so here if I'm
making a new data frame df2 uh from dfdm
the numpy um data frame that I've been
using I rename a column uh so uh all of
a sudden an entire data frame copy
occurs that cost about 8 gigabyte and a
bunch of seconds then I assign a new
column that causes another data frame
copy another 8 gbt uh and then if I drop
a column I get another data frame copy
and we could lose the Temporaries so at
the end we've got 8 gigabytes but there
was another temporary during the
operation and it means that in total 17
seconds were taken in that operation and
about 8 gigabytes and during the
operation there was another 9 gigabytes
of temporary floating around in the
background so that's kind of expensive
uh and if we go and say okay row zero
test mileage column uh assert the value
of it 227,000 mil and if I mod mod ify
it and then check that I've modified it
and check that I haven't modified the
original data frame I get the behavior
that I want but that's kind of expensive
nearly 20 seconds for that uh what if we
turn copy on right on uh then we do the
same operation the same three things
three seconds almost no memory is used
at all but later on if I assert that my
original data frame is not modified and
then I modify sorry I'm checking the
derived data frame then I modify the
derived data frame and then I check it
and check the original then a copy
occurs for that one series that one
series series that's modified and not
the rest of the data in there so that's
much much cheaper so that's kind of
interesting you get faster operations um
and uh and you get the correctness that
you're expecting and a much lower RAM
footprint so this will be turned on in
Panda 3 sometime next year and you can
turn it on with PD options mode copy on
write equals true that's at the top of
the screen there that's worth
experimenting
with if we have a different memory back
end do the rest of our tools work we
might assume and hope that they do but
who knows what the the underlying memory
requirements are uh so here I did a
query using pandas and arrows so dfda
the arrow back end um for my pandas data
frame uh I took all of the vehicles that
passed on this inmemory data set that I
had took a subsample of 10,000 took out
the uh the first year of use and then
filter just for petrol and diesel
engines and then plotted on a scatter
chart on the right hand side using
Seaborn the year of first use versus
mileage you can see blue goes up on the
right hand side that's diesel so diesel
vehic Vehicles high mileage but
generally younger years those Vehicles
wear out and break down due to the high
mileage um and uh in the sort of yellowy
orange petrol Vehicles they can be older
and they generally have much less uh
mileage on them um so great so we can
use our Arrow back end with Seaborn and
scipi and other regular
tools what about polers and we'll do the
same Benchmark in just a second in polar
so polers uh it's not written in Python
it's not written in C it's written in
Rust it's a very different back end uh
it was originally a data frame library
in Rust and then it became much more
popular um when it had a python front
end put around it and that's the polers
that we know it's about three three and
a half years old uh it only understands
Arrow it has no understanding of numpy
it can import from numpy and Export to
numpy but internally it knows nothing
about numpy it's only arrow-based
one-dimensional arrow vectors it's
inherently multicore and parallelized so
things can go very fast than it and
that's kind of interesting but it does
have a different API it also have beta
outof core support for medium data
that's data that fits on a hard drive
drive but doesn't fit into RAM and we'll
see a note on that in a
bit uh so let's do that same operation
in polers so looking for all the
vehicles that have passed taking a sub
sample of 10,000 taking their first use
year and then filtering for petrol and
Diesel and then plotting in Seaborn and
here I've used a KDE plot rather than um
a scatter plot but it's the same data
just to show that we can we can draw
this uh using our regular tools and it
works fine there was no problems using
Seaborn um or scipi I've tested as well
um using Arrow so DF plle PL being the
shorthand for polers uh dfle the eager
data frame so things operated upon every
line operated upon as it's encountered
uh with no query planning we'll get to
the query planner in a moment um so uh
interestingly compared to six months ago
when we ran this exact uh same bit of
code uh polos has become 50% faster
that's really nice uh not a slow down
but a speed up um which is uh and I've
noticed that in Poland there's a bunch
of things who just speed it up in the
last six months was very interesting uh
let's do a slightly more advanced query
uh here on the left with pandas and on
the right with polers so on the left
with pandas an arrow um I take uh I take
uh all the makes all the different
vehicle makes Volkswagen Toyota get
their cylinder capacity that's the
engine size uh do an aggregate operation
on them keep all of the Aggregates where
there are more than 10 items so we can
get a robust statistic uh and then uh do
a sort on the median value uh so we
could uh we could do some research into
vehicle C and engine sizes uh and kind
of weirdly um Panda's narrow takes
nearly 30 seconds for that operation on
the left hand side and contrasts that on
the right hand side with polers and
arrow three seconds nearly 10 times
faster uh so that's kind of interesting
it turns out there's a regression uh six
months ago pandas with arrow uh did that
in half the time but still 15 seconds um
rather than the three seconds in arrows
there's some interesting differences and
changes in behavior um going on in
there so some first conclusions uh panda
and arrow may be better than pandas and
numpy some things are definitely better
if you're using strings you almost
certainly should at least mix and match
um numpy for the regular types that are
used to and arrow for uh for strings in
pandas you just get benefits all around
and dask is moving in that direction
already um you should just do that
there's probably no good reason to stick
with python strings the old way of
handling it in numpy um or you could
just go fullon Arrow uh um but then some
operations like that by maybe they're
slower for you'd have to Benchmark those
yourself polar seems to be faster than
pan as an arrow and polers uses Arrow
internally and the copy on right
optimization in pandas looks like a nice
optimization it's not turned on by
default um but it's recommended now that
we turn it on and start testing our code
because it will be on by default next
year so you should start testing with
copy and right enabled and checking that
your code base uh Works a bit uh also
you know we've got a bunch of benchmarks
here all benchmarks are lies so just be
careful um I mentioned Peril so we
brought a car the Volvo v50 okay the
analysis didn't drive which car we
bought eBay drove the car that we bought
um but uh the analysis backed up the
fact that we were buying this good
robust car that was probably not going
to blow up on us I owned it for less
than 24 hours about 15 miles into
driving the engine hit Max revs it turns
out oil was leaking into the turbo and
self- feeding itself the road covered in
white smoke I had to do an emergency
stop by then the cabin was filling with
white smoke I was sitting there with a
key in my hand like an idiot with the
engine at Max revs and I had to run away
and pH the fiber Brigade and all the
liquid you see on the floor there that's
a mixture of the diesel and the oil and
the coolant from the car this is one of
the Perils of buying an old Banger car
no matter how good its Providence might
be uh so that didn't go on the rally
because that car blew up but we still we
still had a good result uh right back to
data science what if we want to resample
a Time series for a very common data
science operation uh we want to read
paret uh this is in polers now so if I
want to read um a pre-prepared parket
file a couple of years worth of data two
years worth of data I've got this one
pre-prepared parket file I read it into
memory into an eager data frame uh and
then I want to do a resample so just
like a group buy or a Time series um
operation inside pandas we can do all of
this in polers uh and you see here a
group by Dynamic gives me a weekly
resample where I can take all of the
vehicles that passed and sum them up and
that means the graph on the right hand
side I can see that every week in 2021
2022 every week typically we had 600,000
to 700,000 Vehicles passing theot apart
from April and there's a a weird
Behavior everything drops down now this
is into covid we've already had a
lockdown the year before we could
hypothesize a lockdown effect is
occurring here but we can't load more
data into memory because we run out of
ram the data becomes too large for Ram
uh wouldn't it be nice if we could run
the same query with almost no
modification without thinking about it
in polers and it turns out we can uh so
if we want to scan all of the data that
we've got 850 parket files 640 million
rows I Chang the read parket to a scan
parket that becomes a lazy operation
where the query plan becomes enabled um
I had a filter on just to say I want
vehicles from 2018 onwards but you still
got to touch every file to find those
ones the rest of the query is unchanged
I collect the result it takes 13 seconds
and then I get a five-year plot and I
can see indeed that in 2020 in April
when lockdown occurred we get a massive
decline in the number of mots so vehicle
tests occurring because the country's in
lockdown and in previous years we didn't
have that April effect and in the years
in the future then the April effect is
declining as people go back to testing
at that point in the year and things
even out again so it's really nice that
you can just swap that around uh and
test that uh as you're going with polers
uh what if we ask another uh an easy but
larger question uh what's happening with
vehicle ownership per year on this open
data set split by Fuel types we have to
do a little bit of work here um but
really we're saying for every year so
we've got to touch all of those 850
parket FES how many petrol diesel hybrid
and electric cars go through a vehicle
test and vehicle tests lag new sales uh
because you have to do a vehicle test
three years after a vehicle has been uh
purchased um for new vehicles uh so we
only see a couple of electric and
hybrids but the big picture here is that
the thing's going up uh so more people
in the UK are owning cars uh vehicle
ownership Is On The Rise um how would we
do this with desk and what is desk so
dask scales pandas and it scales other
tools to it often known for being the
panda scaler but actually it scales
numpy with the array module um and it
scales regular python containers with
the bag and it provides distributed
computation regardless of data science
tooling uh with delayed and feutures you
make a task graph you then execute that
on a single machine or multiple machines
and maybe your data is distributed on
multiple machines or it's accessed from
different sources um and then you get an
outputs if you're doing a pandas like
operation with a distributed data frame
you get a pandas data frame result
back how do we write a bit of desk that
addresses this query well the the naive
desk uh the easy desk solution is on the
left this is the slower one um we do a
read parket at the top there looking at
Pi Arrow files we look for all vehicles
that have passed we do a little bit of
cleanup we get the year um that the
vehicle uh was tested um and then we're
grouping with fuel type uh and then we
can plot the number of vehicles tested
per year and get that idea of the number
of vehicles on the road takes 42 seconds
it's not bad it's it's easy to read it
will execute and it will complete
there's a new Tool uh that Patrick
hofler introduced yesterday you might
want to catch up on Patrick's video dask
Expressions this is a higher level
wrapper around the underlying dask
operations uh which gives us um a way of
adding a query planner the the thing on
the left naive dask has no query planner
everything is executed one item at a
time just like in pandas there's no
there's no attempt to optimize the query
on the right with dask Expressions there
is a good attempt at optimizing the
query things can be squashed together
potentially repeated computations can be
removed from that graph um and then some
of the operations could be pushed up to
the paret layer rather than being hand
handled in the desk layer afterwards by
just using desk expressions and and
modifying our query slightly query
wasn't implemented um in the release we
used is added now adding optimize into
our call we go from 42 seconds down to
26 and this scales up to larger data
sets this thing's only six months old uh
Matt Rocklin the author of desk told me
about this after our London presentation
in June uh and we've been following it
here we're testing it it seems to work
okay it's it's six months old there are
some issues in there but generally it
seems to work it's definitely worth you
experimenting with it if you're using
dask uh what if we better optimize our
results so we use some hard one
knowledge to optimize things uh back in
June Jes did loads of work he spent days
optimizing one of our more sophisticated
queries for the earlier talk uh We've
kept it a bit simpler here here we
didn't have to do that level of
optimization which is quite nice because
desk in the last six months has improved
anyway they've been a bunch of
performance improvements in there but by
pushing some of these things by hand
back to the paret level um even there we
got a slightly better result to any 3
seconds um but then contrast that with
the polar result on the right hand side
we do a scam parket for a lazy operation
uh we have the same query in there and
it takes 24 seconds and we didn't really
have to do anything it's kind of
interesting um so we didn't have to know
or not to make aers work well on this
single machine multicore um multifile
problem on one hard drive um the the
obvious caveat here is that polers won't
scale to multiple machines whereas Des
can scale to multiple machines um uh
I've highlighted the streaming equals
true on the 32 gig machine we use this
polar's query with streaming equals
false the default it failed it ran out
of ram if you turn streaming equals true
on then you get kind of a batch mode
running which tries to reduce Ram
pressure and on the 32 gig machine and
the 64 gig machine the query performed
just fine so polers should work even if
you've got very large data sets with
very large queries with this
experimental streaming mode is kind of
interesting uh so we haven't checked
lots of things um there's uh there's
just a lot to test right and with with
changes fundamental changes like copy on
right coming through uh in pandas and
Arrow coming through where some
benchmarks improve and some get worse
and some some sub libraries no longer
work the way that they used to uh it's
kind of hard to figure out all those
permutations uh one thing that um I do
use in pandas is number you can use an
engine equals number some of the time to
make some of your operations compiled
and in one of my courses I teach how to
use number to make your numpy based code
uh run compiled number doesn't
understand Arrow so number can't be used
on arrow-based columns inside pandas um
so uh we lose a bunch of our
optimizations uh that occur uh so if
you're doing lots of numeric heavy work
with an engine of number you might want
to stick with the numpy data tapes data
types um and I'm not sure how that's
going to evolved because I don't think
number can understand Arrow at least at
the moment um there's some different
handling of nand versus missing data
between polers and pandas uh it's worth
reading up if you're going to polers uh
you definitely want to read up on how
missing data is handled because Arrow
behind the scenes has a different way of
representing it um there's only partial
psychic learn support um because psychic
learn assumes the Panda's API and polers
does not have the Panda's API psychic
learn could replicate the polar's API or
the panda API but then there are other
apis and I don't want to replicate all
of them so there's work for a data frame
interchange protocol but that's in quite
an early stage at the moment so that's
not yet supported um and then other
things like Arrow times series and
strings maybe they have different
Behavior they do have some different um
functionality um between numpy and arrow
so it's not it's not an easy clean swap
uh maybe on large code basis you want to
go very slow it's definitely worth
experimenting with arrow be it in pandas
or polers uh for Greenfield projects um
I found polar easy to use both when I
first learned it and then subsequently
um pandas of course we all know it um
arrow is great in both it does seem to
at least reduce the memory pressure for
a lot of operations um there are some
differences polers for example day of
week starts counting at one whereas in
pandas it starts counting at zero uh and
some operations in the lazy API in
polers um are missing like sample and
desk also because of its um its lazy
computation nature also has some things
that are missing from pandas so just be
aware that there are some more Educators
you have to think about as you try to
move over I will note that when I
started learning polers it frustrated me
because it told me I couldn't do things
but it guided me in the right direction
and it turns out it makes my thinking
easier as opposed to pandas where there
are 20 ways to solve the same to solve
the one problem that you're trying to
solve so polers kind of forces you down
the right Avenue towards an efficient
computation that is clean and that's
kind of nice so I quite like
it um I think for medium data data
that's bigger than RAM dask and polers
can perform similarly uh dask has a
harder learning curve particularly if
you want to uh go down the optimization
route but it also has support not just
for pandas data frames but numpy and
standard python functions uh with
delayed computation and machine learning
distributed machine learning and it has
really really rich graphical Diagnostics
if you're doing single large machine or
multi machine computation the
Diagnostics and the ability to Cloud
host that um in desk it's really kind of
interesting so it leads to a very very
scalable solution uh if that's the kind
of data set science that you're working
on uh so back to the uh the rally we won
it in the end it turns out it wasn't a
timed rally you had to do challenges
every day we did that it was a charity
rally we won it we got a bunch more
money so we we're able to give a
donation of several thousand pounds to
Parkinson's in a Volkswagen Pat estate
that was 24 years old and which did not
blow up on us didn't have a turbo so
mechanically uh it was more sound uh
next year maybe I get some vehicle
telematics with a Bluetooth dongle maybe
I can do a richer talk on engine
Dynamics uh as we do the rally again
next year uh so summary hey look uh it's
time to experiment if you've got Green
Field projects going on we've got
interesting options you should
definitely try dask you should
definitely try dask Expressions where
you get the optimizations on top of desk
uh you should try polers um and you
should try copy on writing pandas and
you should try the new Arrow back end
you should just experiment with these
things I'll be covering these in my high
performance book for the Third Edition
which will be out in a year or so um you
may just see up on the wall behind me
I've got there are things on the wall
that you can't really see they postcards
that people have sent me if this talk or
other talks I've given in the past have
educated you I'd love to receive a
postcard they make me happy send me a
postcard when you're up a mountain just
send me an email I'll send you my
address I'd love to receive postcards
and I talk about some of these things on
my email on my newsletter not a number.
email I'll put that into the chat
afterwards um and I'll be talking about
all the new things that I discover in
polers and pandas as I carry on with
this this journey um and right now I
think uh we've got a couple of minutes
for some questions maybe um and maybe
jles has been handling those uh thank
you very much uh for
listening I'm going to stop uh the slide
share oh I see the hearts coming up the
screen that's brilliant thank you very
much I see jles has been uh dealing with
all the chat that's brilliant excellent
uh comrade is there anything that's uh
that we need to answer um there is a
question in Q&A is there a project or
effort for multimachine
Polar uh I
believe yes is the short answer I
believe that's the case I know when
Richie started the project he said
absolutely um it would not do uh it was
only in memory wouldn't do streaming
data and it wouldn't do multimachine
data and then he changed the stance on
streaming and then he's uh I've seen a
change in stance um on the multimachine
I don't know when or how that happened
but I believe there at least
investigations and uh if you search for
coiled so coiled is the commercial
company that backs dask the open source
project um Matt Rocklin there the author
of dask has done some um okay you're
very welcome General design
considerations for desk versus spark oh
I don't know if I uh I don't know I
don't have a clean answer to that one um
it looks like pandas to improve
performance and memory footprint are
there still room for improvement of
course there is uh pandas is slow pandas
is single core most of the time pandas
does not have a query planner there's
loads of things that could be fixed in
pandas but pandas was never designed to
operate that way so it's really hard um
there will be more performance
improvements in pandas the team behind
it work really really hard to support us
in the wider Community you should always
thank the panda devs because they've got
a really tough challenge it's a really
popular library that supports lots of
different ways of executing lots of
different queries um they do have big
plans polus is interesting because it's
a new project so it's got to watch
pandas over a decade and pis spark and
other distributed uh data frame tools
and it's it's had a chance to build an
API around all of those learnings
whereas pandas kind of has to play catch
up there um so yeah interesting
differences in those projects but there
is definitely Room to Grow um in p for
things to get
faster
right what else do I see in there view
on Duck DB and this is probably the last
question oh
uh do I have a view on Doc DB um I don't
have a view on Doc DB um except that if
you want to read CSV files you can just
point. DB at them and query them with
SQL even though they're very large and
it just works which is dead impressive
no importing it just worked um and I've
had other people tell me that in some
communities uh duck DB is pandas no one
uses pandas there they use duck DB and
it has for their problems similar
performance um for large certainly paret
columnar data sets um so I think for The
Right Use case duck DB is a very very
solid choice and Charles has linked to a
benchmark in their spark Dax dask uh
duck DB and polers uh that ppcb marks at
scale which Matt Rocklin did recently
and that that that um included um some
comments about Richie V and the
collaboration uh that's a really good
video to watch and that shows some of
the performance differences um for
medium and large data sets of du DB
versus the other tools uh it's a solid
tool I know people who use it and love
it so Dr DB is worth of
consideration cool thank you Ian thank
you J always a pleasure very much uh and
I think that concludes
our uh and our keynote session is coming
up next so uh see everyone else there
great thank you comrade see you
guys